[Applauso]
[Musica]
come si arriva da un paesino di tremila
anime a una città di due milioni e mezzo
di abitanti
e come si naviga tra le acque increspate
di un oceano con l'unico scopo di
realizzare un sogno ma soprattutto come
si affronta al mare quando in tempesta
quando la meta contorni sfocati
siamo stanchi da un lungo viaggio è
l'unica soluzione sembrerebbe quella di
tirare i remi in barca
la mia è la storia di un sogno
realizzato attraverso una valigetta di
pelle piccolina è piuttosto leggera
avevo 8 anni quando i miei genitori
hanno esaudito la mia richiesta di un
microscopio
con quella valigetta mi sentivo
invincibile la portavo con me ovunque
andassi al mare montagna in campagna
giravo per ore le foglie tra le mani è
affascinata dalla regolarità di quelle
striature da quelle vene delle quali
scorrevano linfa vitale che cambiava
colore a seconda delle piante da quelle
raccoglievo quelli microscopio mi
consentiva di entrare in un mondo
invisibile ad occhio nudo e di scorgere
la vita che gli altri non riuscivano a
vedere con il tempo le valigie sono
diventate più pesanti e più grandi e le
distanze che percorro rientrano oggi
nell'ordine di migliaia di chilometri
saltello intorno al mondo alla ricerca
di microscopi più sofisticati che mi
consentano di entrare in un mondo ancora
più piccolo quello nanoscopico per
comprendere gli ingranaggi che rendono
il nostro corpo una macchina tanto
meravigliosa e perfetta quanto fragile
curiosando oggi ne nei bagagli
trovereste un computer un camice qualche
vestito elegante tacchi alti e una
passione enorme quella che mi ha spinto
un giorno a guardare in faccia il mio
sogno è a rincorrerlo intorno al mondo
nata con come una curiosità la mia
passione per la scienza mi ha
letteralmente travolto ha guidato la mia
vita l'ha usata alla continua ricerca di
risposte piccole scoperte si incastrano
ogni giorno a puzzle iniziati da altri e
alcune hanno preso delle strade
indipendenti e con quelle è iniziata
realmente la mia avventura entusiasmante
per qualcuno è bizzarra di sicuro
autentica spesso estenuante il tempo che
passa da una scoperta all'ipotesi
successiva è impercettibile i motori
della mente continuano a funzionare e
non si spengono con le luci del
laboratorio la sera
anzi è proprio quando ho deciso di
prendermi una pausa che arrivano le
soluzioni ai problemi in quel caso non
c'è nient'altro da fare se non portarsi
le maniche e ricominciare a lavorare per
il riposo ci penseremo domani
nel mio laboratorio negli stati uniti
studio sviluppiamo degli approcci che
siano in grado di risvegliare il
potenziale rigenerativo del nostro corpo
quando annientato da una malattia o da
un'infezione perde coscienza delle
proprie capacità
come boe prendiamo ispirazione proprio
dai processi che utilizza per funzionare
e cerchiamo di capire gli errori che
commette quando smette di farlo con il
tempo mi sono accorta che questo corpo
sa molto di più da insegnarci di quanto
potessimo immaginare
la trasporto più importante quello che
mi affascina di più è la socialità dei
processi biologici scoprire che per
funzionare questo corpo ha bisogno di
cellule che necessariamente devono
comunicare tra di loro
lavorando nel campo della medicina
rigenerativa io studio
le informazioni che le cellule staminali
che sono delle cellule con un
grandissimo potenziale terapeutico
scambiano con le cellule circostanti
utilizzano dei veri e propri pacchetti
di parole che cambiano a seconda del
programma che vogliono attivare
quelle parole hanno un potere enorme per
che regolano i processi che ci tengono
in salute
succede però a volte che le lettere di
quelle parole vengono assemblate in
maniera incorretta e attivino nelle
cellule che le ricevono dei processi
completamente aberranti aberranti con
conseguenze negative
devastanti sul nostro organismo
molto spesso quando penso ad un ambiente
infiammato mi vengono in mente le
interazioni che avvengono spesso nella
società perché se il corpo sa benissimo
come reagirà ad un insulto da che cosa
deriva la possibilità che degeneri
quando le cellule staminali vengono
esposte ad un ambiente
infiammato per un po di tempo
mi ricordo le cellule staminali sono
delle cellule molto giovani il cui
potenziale si definisce sulla base delle
informazioni che ricevono
reagiscono a questo ambiente
in un modo assolutamente positivo e
propositivo
cercano di risolvere la soluzione alla
situazione quindi inviano messaggi
parole che cercano di convincere le
cellule circostanti a reagire
rappresentano esse stesse uno stimolo
per le cellule circostanti devono
ricordare loro chi sono e per quale
motivo si trovano lì
questa situazione che riguarda i
processi biologici mi ricorda molto
quello che succede quando dei giovani
vengono esposti ad una sfida la prima
reazione è quella di dare il meglio di
sé mobilitarsi ver per il raggiungimento
dell'obiettivo
mostrarsi propositivi e positivi agire
quando però l'ambiente è troppo
stressato e vengono esposti ad un
ambiente chiuso un ambiente
incancrenito
perdono le loro i loro strumenti perdono
le loro risorse e come le cellule
smettono di lottare
in quei casi il nostro corpo ha bisogno
di un intervento esterno
noi oggi la chiamiamo terapia
l'effetto di un ambiente è enorme e
capita spesso di avere bisogno di uno
stimolo l'ambiente ha il potere di
sostenere sia sostenerci nel
raggiungimento di un obiettivo
oppure di annientarci per sempre
non è poi così che
si avvia la strada che sa che che
incappiamo nella strada verso la
rinuncia a un sogno forse attraverso le
parole di chi ci ricorda che il sistema
e questo è quindi ci dobbiamo
accontentare
oppure attraverso
la sensazione che
qualcuno che ci ripete che
queste sono le opportunità e che le
opportunità della scienza sono limitate
da pannaggio soltanto di alcuni
di alcuni fortunati
oppure che esiste una gerarchia da
rispettare e che l'unica possibilità di
fare carriera e l'attesa per me questo è
un vero e proprio paradosso ho visto
realtà accademiche
perdere giovani brillanti
seguendo degli schemi che nulla avevano
a che fare con i loro talenti e con le
loro capacità tantomeno con
l'innovazione tecnologica e scienziati
acclamati a livello internazionale
perdere la loro entusiasmo per la
ricerca e rinunciare al loro sogno per
lo stesso motivo
lavorando a contatto con i giovani io mi
sono accorta che siamo troppo
concentrati sulla trasmissione di
nozioni tecniche che peraltro riescono a
recuperare anche da libri o da internet
che ci dimentichiamo di raccontare la
scienza per quella che è
una fan un'esperienza emozionante
affascinante che però richiede una sfida
professionale e personale costanti ci
dimentichiamo di raccontare le
difficoltà le cadute le porte in faccia
le ipotesi che non vengono testate ci
dimentichiamo di mostrare ai ragazzi che
hanno voglia di intraprendere questo
percorso
la vita a cui vanno incontro
spesso io ricordo il primo giorno del
mio incarico da docente universitaria
ero piuttosto giovane nonostante avessi
un pedigree da ricercatrice
internazionale di tutto rispetto
sulle facce delle studentesse e degli
studenti
era chiarissimo il dubbio che fossi
proprio io
la docente di turno
nei loro occhi ritrovai i miei quelli di
una studentessa con una speranza nel
cuore quella di diventare una scienziata
e con
tanta voglia di imparare decisi quindi
in quel momento di modificare il
contenuto di quella lezione e di
raccontare loro quello che la bruna de
vent'anni aveva sempre desiderato
la storia il percorso che mi aveva
portato fin lì
trovai a raccontarlo dosando molto bene
e successi ed insuccessi e
cercando di dare il giusto peso alle
gioie di una scoperta
e all'amarezza dei momenti che mi
avevano portato fino ad essa
quei momenti che inevitabilmente
arrivano quando gli esami sono stati
superati quando la corona d'alloro è
ormai appesa alla parete
quando nonostante magari una carriera
brillante cominciamo ad avere dei dubbi
su
quella che è la nostra missione o ci
sembra che il futuro non sia così chiaro
non che esista un protocollo da seguire
per superare certi momenti quelle quello
che io però so è che quella lezione ebbe
un effetto potentissimo attraverso il
racconto autentico della mia
vulnerabilità sono riuscito a
normalizzare quella sensazione
fastidiosa di fallimento che sapevo
sarebbe prima o poi arrivato anche per
loro
a distanza di anni l'effetto di quelle
parole è tuttora vivo e mi onora la
sensazione sapere che quei ragazzi
considerano quel racconto quelle parole
uno spazio in cui rifugiarsi nei momenti
di difficoltà ed incertezza uno spazio
di condivisione
dal quale prendere la rincorsa verso il
futuro è per loro oggi che sono qui a
raccontare questo argomento piuttosto
scomodo quello che voglio raccontare che
è successo anche a me qualche anno fa di
decidere di appendere quella famosa
valigetta al chiodo e di ritirarmi nelle
retrovie di una vita lontana dalla
scienza ero stremata da continui rifiuti
e mi sembrava che la mia scienza non
avesse i contorni delineati che pensavo
dovesse avere ed ero anche imbambolata
da un coro di voci che facevano non
facevano che ripetermi che sulla soglia
dei 30 anni ero brava
giovane e dovevo aspettare
ricordo che in quel periodo di dubbi
esistenziali mi invitarono a tenere un
seminario in uno dei centri di medicina
rigenerativa
più prestigiosi prestigiosi d'europa
parlai di cellule staminali parlai di
biomateriali
parlai anche di nanomedicina lo feci con
la stessa passione con cui racconto la
mia assenza chi ha voglia di ascoltarla
quel giorno però lo feci con una nota di
tristezza perché sapevo che sarebbe
stata l'ultima presentazione scientifica
della mia vita
seduto in prima fila riconobbe lo
sguardo di una persona che sempre aveva
creduto in me durante gli anni del
dottorato
al termine dell'intervento si avvicinò
per congratularsi dei risultati che
avevo mostrato che aveva ottenuto negli
anni che mi avevano visto spostarmi dal
regno unito all'america con
l'atteggiamento
aperto di chi
vede la scienza come un'opportunità e la
mia giovane età come una risorsa quella
conversazione fu sufficiente per farmi
sentire ancora una scienziata
purtroppo non fu sufficiente per farmi
cambiare idea e anzi gli raccontai della
mia decisione
in quel momento mi stupì perché dalla
sua bocca non uscì neppure una parola di
sostegno non provò in nessun modo a fare
a farmi cambiare idea
tornai a casa e tornai alla mia abilità
e ai miei dubbi in realtà la decisione
l'avevo già presa ricevetti qualche
settimana più tardi una mail
nell'oggetto
lassie questo è quello che sei quando
fai ciò che più ti appassiona
incuriosita aprila l'allegato e trovai
questa foto una foto che quella persona
aveva trovato sulla pagina web della
società internazionale di ricerca sulle
cellule staminali l'avevano utilizzata
per ispirare i giovani ad avvicinarsi
alla scienza ed è una mia foto in quegli
occhi ho ritrovato il motivi il motore
di tanto vagare intorno al mondo di una
vita lontana da casa
quella foto è stata sufficiente per
riattivare la mia missione per farmi
riconoscere le mie aspirazioni farmi
riprendere in mano la mia vita e
ricominciare
andare avanti quella foto ebbe lo stesso
effetto terapeutico delle ter del dl
delle strategie che sviluppiamo
risveglio al potenziale chi era n
non mi restava che creare un nuovo
ambiente e con un nuovo ambiente
ho creato una nuova esperienza per la
scienziata che oggi vive dentro di me ed
eccomi qua a fare quello che mi riesce
meglio e più mi appassiona la scienza
con i giovani
la scienza che vorrei che voglio per i
giovani è una scienza vulnerabile
racconta è racconta il rischio di dover
sbaragliare i limiti linguistici
geografici racconta la necessità di
doversi spingere oltre quello che
vediamo e oltre quello che sappiamo
racconta insegna a navigare nel mare
dell'incertezza
e pretende che ci mettiamo a nudo che ci
apriamo al al giudizio degli altri
perché la nostra idea soltanto se
valutata da diverse prospettive può
essere resa vincente
la scienza che io vedo è una scienza che
sa usare
sono le sconfitte a forgiare la corazza
del ricercatore che non rinuncia alla
sua missione sono i numeri che non ha a
dargli il coraggio di andare avanti e di
mostrare solo a se stesso che ce la può
fare e sono
in una reta a far attivare dentro di sé
quella voce che continua a dire che
l'innovazione non può aspettare sono le
ipotesi non testate a rappresentare la
base per la prossima scoperta
ho avuto il piacere e l'onore di
celebrare il cinquantesimo anniversario
dell'allunaggio con gli astronauti
i direttori delle operazioni di volo
delle missioni apollo e da quel giorno
una frase continua a ronzarmi pennella
testa
avevamo una missione e a nessuno venne
in mente che eravamo troppo giovani per
compierla grazie
[Applauso]